Without further ado, please
help me. Welcome Joe. Thank you.
So thank you. Thank you, Mary for the,
for the great introduction
texts that everybody at Google.
And also I wanted to take my longtime
colleague, Terry Fong, who kind of, uh,
with along with Mary manages the,
the NASA Google relationship for inviting
me to give this presentation. So I'm,
I'm, I'm thrilled to be here. This
is actually my first time on the,
on the Google campus.
And so I've obviously everybody
has read and heard a lot about it,
but to actually see it in action
is, is wonderful for me. Um,
I'm going to talk a little bit about,
uh, the Mars sample return mission. Uh,
it's an idea that we've had at NASA for,
for quite some time and we're actually
ever so slowly inching our way toward,
toward executing it.
And I wanted to talk particularly about
the technologies that are necessary to
do it.
You'll see a few charts downstream.
I'm going to show you all the video
that's kind of an animation of Mars sample
return. And you're going to see a few
places where we're miracles are necessary.
You'll, you'll, you'll, you'll know what
I mean when you see it on the, on the,
on the animation.
And that's code for we need to develop
the technology to do whatever it is that
we're trying, trying to do. So
when you'll see that you'll,
you'll see that this mission is an
incredible system engineering challenge.
It's like doing Apollo with no astronauts.
We even, it even includes, you know,
going to another planet,
landing, doing some stuff.
They're launching into orbit
around that planet and coming back.
So it's very analogous to what we
did at the moon wood with Apollo.
But there's no humans involved,
at least not directly. Um, and to,
to imagine doing all the things that
we did in the Apollo with no humans is,
is quite an undertaking. So without
further ado, let me launch into charts.
I'm going to try to run till about 45
past the hour and Mary will give me a cue
to wrap it up and then we can, um, we can
have a little bit of of interaction on,
on a question.
She went to a,
and I also understand there's a number
of people watching this online and I'm
not sure if there's a mechanism for them
to be able to ask questions, but uh,
they, they can get in touch with
me. Okay. So, so Mary are at Google.
Um, if you want to ask a question
and you're online, you're not in,
in the room here, so let me go
ahead and get, get going and we'll,
we'll work it out as we,
as we go.
So I'm a little bit of an
overview and by the way,
my slides are going to be graphics
heavy and texts, uh, light. Uh,
so we can, we can talk about
the, the, the core stuff in a,
and I have a number of videos that I
want to show you and I'm going to, um,
in order for me to talk comprehensively
about Msr, it takes about four hours.
And so we only have less than one then.
So I've had to be a little bit selective
and I instead of trying to like give
you a shallow view of everything,
I've chosen a few things that I really
want to dive in and talk about it and I
think that's a better experience
for you and it's fun to talk about.
And if you're still interested,
I gave Maria a longer version of this
presentation that has more information in
it and you're welcome to peruse that and
I have my contact information anyway.
I'll give you a little bit of context
for what we're trying to accomplish with
the Mars exploration program
that's in instantiated at NASA now.
And when I talk about Mars exploration,
I'm going to talk mostly about the robotic
exploration on Mars using rovers and
orbiters.
Obviously there's a big effort at NASA
associated with preparing for humans to
go to Mars. Um, I'll touch
on that peripherally at the
end of the presentation,
but most of my talk is about doing this
with rovers and orbiters and so forth.
So talk a little bit about the context
for for exploration and what is it that
we're trying to accomplish
as a blend of science,
technology and inspiration and which
I think is a product that we at NASA
sometimes don't appreciate how much we're
delivering that along with delivering
science and technology.
Talk a little bit about this,
this a Mars sample return mission
and then talk about some of the key
technologies that include things like
how we get the samples off the surface of
Mars,
how we kind of gobble up this thing that's
a size of a basketball and Mars orbit
and bring it back to Earth.
I want to talk about in
particular a really cool
application for superconductors
to assist us in the,
in the sort of trapping of of this
basketball and Moore's orb is called flux
painting and then I want to talk a
little bit about the fact that the marsh
samples, we have a love hate
relationship with them. There are,
there are Frenemies,
I guess we want to study them and we
want to bring them back to earth and
studying our laboratories.
But we also have to account for the
possibility that there might be biological
activity in those samples and therefore
we need to treat them as if they're
potentially hazard and not release these
things into the Earth's biosphere until
we've made sure that it's safe.
And this love hate relationship with the
sample actually drives the engineering
of the mission.
And I'll talk more about that and now,
and then at the end if
we do have any time,
we'll talk about some of the longer term
stuff like flying helicopters at Mars
and I'm landing on a,
on a pinpoint where right now we land with
miles of uncertainty of where we land,
etc. So that's kind of the,
the, the, the outline. So let
me talk a little bit about,
about context and I won't go
through this point by point,
but I just wanted to make
the point that we, um,
within NASA there are sort of four
major organizations that, that are,
are responsible for the NASA missions.
There's one that's responsible
for aeronautics so that
one of the A's and NASA
stands for aeronautics.
Even though I think NASA as much
more better known for the space side.
Within the space domain, we have the
human exploration and operations.
Those are the guys who operate this
international space station and are
preparing to send humans to Mars.
There is a space technology
mission directorate,
which as the name implies is responsible
for developing new technologies that
can be applied across the
board and NASA and beyond.
And then there's what we call the Science
Mission Directorate in the Science
Mission Directorate is responsible for
delivering science results like you're
seeing from Hubble space telescope like
you're saying from the Mars Rovers.
And that's the,
the,
the mission directorate that that
operates the NASA Mars missions.
So we have,
you know,
countless journal articles and papers and
covers of nature magazine and so forth
that that have resulted from,
from the exploration of Mars.
And so we've delivered a
really wide variety of key
science findings like before
the Mars exploration program began.
We didn't really know how
pervasive water wasn't Mars.
And it turns out their water has been
extremely pervasive at Mars in the ancient
times.
It was wet and warm and
much more habitable for the
kinds of life that we are
familiar with on earth.
And then something happened and
all of that water went away.
And Mars has now this dry cold desert.
And because earth and Mars are kind of
brother and sister in, in
the, in the planetary family,
it would be really nice
for us to understand what
happened to all of that water
on Mars. Why did escape and, um,
if you're selfish and you don't want it
to happen to you in Earth or maybe your,
your grandchildren's grandchildren's
grandchildren downstream,
it'd be really nice to understand that.
So science is a,
is a big aspect of what we do.
Tick engineering and
technology development is
another big aspect of what the
Mars program delivers back to not only
NASA but to the world at large. Um,
many of the autonomous systems that are
now being implemented in driverless cars
got their start as NASA tried to figure
out how to operate rovers on the surface
of another planet where we couldn't
have direct human intervention.
And Terry is one of the
world's experts in that field.
And I hope one day he mans up and a and
comes and gives a talk here at Google on
all of the cool stuff that he's been
working on with his colleagues at Ames.
I'm sorry for a little internal joke.
Anyway,
we were developing a whole
variety of technologies that
not only serve, you know,
sort of a localized NASA interests,
like landing more stuff on Mars,
which is a very specialized application,
but things that,
that helped the world at large.
And then the last one, and, and,
and like I said it in some
of my colleagues at Nasa,
they want to talk about the science
and they want to talk about the sort of
technology as applies submissions.
But I think that one of our
greatest products is inspiration.
And for me it was
unbelievable to be at JPL. Uh,
the night that we landed curiosity. And
to see that in Times Square Times Square,
it was lit up with the images
that were coming back from Mars.
And when those first, the landing itself
was sort of a technological achievement.
But when those first thumbnail images
came back and we knew we were safe on
Morris,
that was a human story.
That was the story of all the
people through their lives.
And you guys know what this is like
to work long hours, nights, weekends,
and feel like personally responsible
for the success. In our case missions,
you're in your case products or something
that may Google is trying to develop,
but that notion that you've invested
in yourself personally and something no
machine can ever,
ever take away that human inspiration.
So I think that's one of the
major products that we deliver.
Coming back to science,
um,
there's kind of four things to organize
our scientific exploration of Mars
number one. And you know,
these are written as if they're
like equals, but they're,
they're actually not finding
funny life is the big one.
It's the first among equals. That's,
that's the one that, you know, if, if,
if we were to find life,
even microbial life,
either evidence of it in the ancient
history of Morrison kind of fossilized
context or extent life,
um,
that would be just a unbelievable change
in the way in which people on earth
think of themselves and think of us as
not being alone in this, in this universe.
I'm not to be downplayed or
are the other goals. Like,
you know, I talked a
little bit about the, the,
the processes and the history
of the climate on Mars.
So even if you could care less about as
an ethereal discussion about whether or
not there's life on another planet,
maybe if you're a little
more self centered or are
thinking about the future for
your kids and kids and his kids.
And I'm just this notion of Le
Let's not let happen to Earth.
What happened to Mars? Understanding,
um, how the surface of Mars,
uh,
evolve in the interior of Mars that is
actually vastly different from Earth's.
And one advantage that we have, the
earth is constantly reinventing itself.
The earth. We have these
play, these tectonic plates.
I keep moving around and changing
things and there's constant upwellings.
I'm in the ocean and on on
land and things get recycled.
So something that's been on the surface
of the earth a million years ago is
almost certainly not on the
surface of the earth anymore.
It's been somehow turn underneath.
Mars is not like that.
Maurice has been very stable for
millions and millions of years.
So you have things that are on the Mars
surface that have always been on the
Mars surface.
And from a scientific standpoint,
it actually makes it a lot easier to
understand the history of Mars than we,
than we enjoy here on earth.
And then the last goal from a science
standpoint is preparing for eventual human
exploration. And what we mean
is from a science standpoint,
understand the processes on Mars.
It might affect human explanation and
understand how the atmosphere works.
Understand if as the surface of
Mars is the, what we call regolith,
which is fancy for dirt.
The dirt on Mars is that toxic to humans.
So that was a big question we have when
the astronauts went to the moon and it's
even more likely to be an
issue at Mars that that the,
the regolith might actually include some
things that are not healthy for humans
to come in direct contact with.
So getting ready for human
exploration is a big deal.
You guys probably know that you've
been sending rovers to Mars.
You may not know that we've kind of
had three styles of these rovers.
The first one was sojourner of which,
which flew in in 1997 and it lasted about
90 days on the surface of Mars and it
operated in an area the size of
this room never got outside of that.
It only could talk back to the
base station that was nearby.
So if it ever got very far away it would
lose contact with the base station.
And it was, it was really a
technology demonstration in,
in 1997 so fast forward to 2004
seven years beyond that we send to,
we sent twins spirit and opportunity.
The Mars exploration rovers of those are
about the size of a table and they way
in the neighborhood of 300 pounds each
when they land and spirit lasted for
seven years before it got stuck
in sand and the winter came,
its solar panels can no longer keep it
warm and we think it froze to death.
However, Opportunity more
than 10 years later, in fact,
12 years now has gone
more than 40 kilometers.
So it's finished a marathon
on the surface of Mars.
It was only supposed to last for 90 days
and it always supposed to go for 600
meters and it's now gone
well over 10 40 kilometers.
So what I say is, Oh, we paid too
much of that system. You know,
things should have died a long
time ago. Anyway, but that's,
that's how we do it at JPL.
And then finally, curiosity,
which I think almost all of
you are directly familiar with.
We launched it in 2011 it landed in 2012
it's still operating on Mars and it's
one of the things that proved that Mars
was in fact a habitable place because
within its first two kilometers of roving,
once it landed at Mars,
it rove through a stream bed.
And I mean it's like absolutely no,
no questions asked a stream bed.
So we knew that there was flowing water
on the surface of Mars at some time in
the past and it was direct proof when
curiosity roll through that that stream
bed. Just to give you a sense, we
have not launched these guys yet, uh,
to Maura's maybe sometime in the future,
but I just wanted to give you some
context for the size of these systems.
So sojourner or size of like
a toaster oven, curiosity,
opportunity and spirit.
The size of the table.
And then curiosity is the size of a,
of an SUV.
So it weighs 900 kilograms
was about 2000 pounds.
And if we're going to
ever send humans to Mars,
we now know how to put down
a curiosity class payload.
And you don't have to put down a
metric ton onto the surface of Mars.
If we're going to put humans on Mars,
we need to learn how to land like 20 tons
is what a human landing system will be.
So when you had to increase our,
our entry descent and landing
capability but at 20 times. Okay,
so here is sort of a quickie summary
of everything that's happened since the
turn of the century.
The turn of the Millennium 2001 we've,
we've started and we've been flying
a set of rovers and fit we call fixed
landers that that stay
in one place and then,
and then a series of orbiters that
perform a variety of functions.
They all have scientific instruments
that are looking down at Mars and asking
questions about the geology or trying
to do laser altimetry so we understand
what's going on in that. Some of them were
looking at the atmosphere around Mars.
Um,
all of our orbiters also do secondary
jobs and include relay and communications
from the rover. So if the rover
had to talk directly back to Earth,
that's a very challenging
communication link.
It's a lot easier for the rover to
scored information up to an orbiter which
then can transmit the information
back back to her sleep,
what we call calm relay, communication
relay function, and also these orbiters.
Many of the of the recent
ones are equipped with cameras
that look down and they
look at places that we might choose to
go in the future and they do what we call
landing site reconnaissance. So they take
pictures and they say, hey, this, this,
I mean it's ironic from a,
from a safety of landing standpoint,
you want to land this thing on a nice
flat rock free parking lot or from us.
That's not where the cool science is.
A science is up in the mountains and
so you have to find these areas on Mars
that have both a safe place to land but
also have good science and your buys.
So what you want to fly,
what you want to do is you
want to land in the foothills.
So these reconnaissance orbiter as a kind
of trying to find the foothills where
you have a nice safe place to land but
cool stuff very nearby is the idea.
And so we've been flying these things
in this mission context since the,
since 2001 a variety of orbiters.
Most of them are NASA but there's some
from other countries and including places
like the European space agency
are just collections of countries.
And then here are the rovers.
And then we start to get into the future
of next year we're going to launch one
of our fixed lenders called insight,
which is going to explore the interior
geology of Mars. And then, um,
I imagine that you all by virtue of being
interested in space know that space x,
which is a private company,
is talking about going to Mars with one
of their own unmanned systems that they
call Red Dragon,
which is an adaptation of the capsule
that they are delivering to the space
station now to deliver crew and cargo.
So they're thinking when this chart was
maybe thinking about going in 2018 just
recently,
they've adjusted their plant and now
targeting 2020 is their first mission to
Mars. And they, as you probably also
know, operate, uh, at a different,
in a different risk posture, in a
different mission cadence than NASA does.
They're much more risk
tolerant and they're able to
execute things more quickly
than we are at NASA.
And so they're actually talking about
going every opportunity to Mars,
which comes along every 26 months. We
can launch missions to Mars. So I'm,
I can't wait to see what space x is
able to accomplish, uh, when they're,
when they're in the position to be able
to land on a routine basis of every
Maura's opportunity.
Um,
now I want to transition to the future
and what's going to happen in the 2020s
and beyond.
Um,
we have a next Mars rover mission,
call it, we call it Mars 2020.
It'll get a inspirational name soon,
soon. Please send, send in your, uh,
your, your entries for that.
But for the time being,
we call it Mars 2020 which
is also a pressure ourselves
to launch the darn thing.
It's 2020 and not in 2022 and then we're
thinking about what's next and what's
next is very clearly and unequivocally
Mars sample return in. I'll,
I'll talk in the next set of slides about
the fact that we need an orbiter to do
that.
And we need another lander that includes
that rocket that I was talking about
that launches the samples
off the surface of Mars.
And that's a decade of the 2020s.
And then downstream from the 2020
is there's a lot more uncertain.
We're not clear whether
we'll have developed enough
infrastructure to be serious
about sending humans to
Mars and the 2030s. Um,
and so we're hedging a little and thinking
about ideas for either more robotic
missions that are continuing the science
exploration of Mars or if we want to
transition more to supporting
human missions to Mars,
which would also do science, but in
a different, in a different context.
So we kind of have a number of pathways
that that we could go in the 30s but for
the 2020 is it's all about
Mars sample return. Um,
Mars sample return is
not a new idea at all.
We've been thinking about it since the
1970s this notion of not only going to
Mars and doing in situ science with
instruments that are carried on some thing
or bitter rover lander,
but actually bringing samples back and
have wide variety of ways of doing that.
I mean,
if you defocus your eyes on what you're
trying to accomplish and you just say,
listen, I want to get a bag
of rocks back from Mars.
You can think about ones that have much
more elaborate roofing systems or you
can think about what we call a
grab sample where you'd land,
he wouldn't rove at all. He just reached
down from wherever you land in a pickup,
a handful of this stuff and put it in the,
in the math and you and you launch.
The scientists don't like
that idea by the way.
They want a diverse set of
samples that they have selected,
not just whatever happened
to be underneath the rocket
when it touches down. Um,
but the thing that I really
love about this, uh, uh,
about this slide is number one,
back in the day when they were like
doing these things as paintings,
they actually still reuse things.
So when you look at this one
up here and this one down here,
totally different concepts,
but it's got the same background.
So like somebody copied and background.
The only thing I really love
about this one is, um, if you can
you see right here,
here's the rover with all the samples
and then there's the map over there and
there's this big valley in between and
you can almost like see this question
more coming out of the head
of the rover. Go ahead. Oh No,
you're on the other side of the valley.
I'm I ever going to get there.
So I don't know who made that painting,
but they were not Amar system engineer.
They were a pure artists. But I love
that. I love that picture. And as I said,
a variety of different ways of,
of doing more sample return,
but it turns out,
but when you do defocus your eyes and
think about what it would take to bring
back a sample from Mars, um, there's
kind of four things that you gotta do.
You got to get the samples,
you've got to get them off Mars.
You've got to somehow get them,
you know,
from that vicinity of Mars back to Earth.
And then once you get them down here,
you have to safely and, and, uh, without
while maintaining scientific integrity,
you know,
you have to study them.
So these four functions are
totally independent of any
particular architecture.
Um,
and then as we'd like to do at NASA,
we like to split big
problems into small problems.
You start thinking about functions.
These are thinking about what
elements might be able to execute.
So in the color coding before we had
these four different things, blue, orange,
green and purple, um, and then you start
to decompose these things into their,
into their various and sundry functions.
And you start to think about specific
systems that might be able to do that.
So for instance, this whole thing about
getting the samples and both by the way,
um, here's an, I'll pass
it around. Here's what,
here's a model of the
two that we're going to,
to stick the rock cores in and we
will collect some 30 ish of these.
It depends on how the mission goes.
We might collect as few as 20 and get
still considered to be a mission success,
but they go into this thing.
So it's about the size of a cigar tube.
The Model I have here is a
purely solid model. There's,
they're hollow for the real flight in
implementation and they've got all kinds
of Gizmos and stuff in here. But this
is roughly the size of the sample.
And the sample goes in the, in
the shank here in the shaft. Um,
so we, in this context, we envision a
rover that would collect the samples.
I would leave them on the surface of Mars.
We're kind of like a drunken sailor.
And then we collect a sample and
we throw it over our shoulder.
And we just trundle away.
Actually we don't,
we put it down really carefully and we
take a bunch of pictures of it from all
kinds of different directions so we know
exactly where it is to go back to go
back and pick up those tubes and we
pick up those tubes from uh, from uh,
another mission that that flies later
than this caching system that will fly in
20,
20 as part of the 2020 rover system.
And that actually contains
two major elements.
One is another rover to go out and pick
up those samples and return them to the
man of the Mars descent vehicle,
which is the rocket that flies on that,
on that mission.
So that mission carries a fetch
rover and carries the Mavs rocket.
And then we had this thing that's that.
So you've executed the blue stuff,
you've acquired in cash, the samples,
you execute that orange stuff,
you launched samples into Mars' orbit,
then you come and you capture
that sample container,
we call it the oss and says basketball
size thing and in return and landed on
earth. And we have a variety of different
ideas on how you might land on earth.
But the most common one is that it
goes splat on the desert in Utah and
protecting that sample so we don't break
the egg open and let the samples out is
one of the major engineering
challenges associated with this.
And then there's all the stuff
associated with, you know,
opening up the egg and getting
the samples out and studying them.
So let's back up for a second and,
and it's, it will be completed.
This was the first question
that I asked when I,
when I first encountered the notion of
more sample return over a decade ago in
my careers. And wait a second,
why are we doing this? I mean,
this is a very expensive way to study
these samples. Why don't we just,
if we're going to sink a
lot of money into this,
why don't we just sync that money into
making better instruments that can get
the same science that we're trying
to get from our laboratories,
but we do it at Mars? Well, it turns
out that that's not really possible. Um,
number one was at the, at the way
that we do sample science involves,
um,
very complex sample preparation that
involves either hands on or direct human
guided slicing and dicing of of things
and preparing specimens for spectroscopy
or microscopy that we just don't
have the technology today to do.
So we would not be able to study them
as well using an Institchu instrument as
we would back on earth. Um, some of the,
these instruments are still
the size of rooms and I mean,
I know this is the analogous to, you know,
room sized computers that now, you know,
slip into your pocket. But the reality
is in terms of space exploration,
we're still back in the or or laboratory
science for analyzing the samples were
still back in those days where the,
where the stuff that you need is the
size of a room. It's not the size of a,
of an iPhone or a Google phone.
Um,
lastly,
you don't always know what you want
to study and when you do it in situ,
the investigations that you can do with
your in situ robot is only as good as
that instrument that you
put on the system. Whereas
if you bring a sample back,
it can sit in containment for 20 years
and all of a sudden you've got a new
instrument that's able to do analysis
that we never could do when we first flew
the mission. And that's the case with
the Apollo Moon rocks. They're, they're,
they're, they're housed largely at the
Johnson Space Center in Houston, Texas.
And then they're distributed
out to investigators.
And one of the motivations for the
distribution of these things are new
instrument capabilities
that have come a long,
long past when those samples came
back from the moon. So there's,
there's ample motivation, um, to
not try to do sample, you know,
to not try to replace the sample return
mission with Jess in situ exploration.
Here's a trying to summarize this
sort of three mission context,
but actually then the
next video animation.
I'm going to show you guys as
much better at doing this job.
We call this a bad chart
because earth is on the bottom.
Mars is on the top and if we really did
this correctly, we would be hanging the,
the rover upside down, um, showing
that it's all being done on Mars.
But you see the sort of three mission
thing, Mars 2020 collect sample tubes.
You can fly the orbiter and the,
and the lander mission in either order,
it doesn't much matter,
but you have to retrieve the tubes,
launch them into Mars' orbit,
collect them and bring them back to Earth.
And hopefully if this video works well,
if we want to understand the potential
for life elsewhere in the solar system,
our neighboring planet,
Mars is a great place to go.
Waiting on Mars or rock samples that
hold clues to whether Mars ever had an
environment suitable for small
lifeforms called microbes.
Scientists would love to collect these
special rocks and bring them back to
study up close in laboratories here
on earth. However you tackle it.
Returning samples from Mars is
definitely a complicated problem,
but mission planners are already
testing technologies to make the future
possible, so how can we
actually get a sample for Mars?
Mission planners have several ideas. One
is to build three different spacecraft,
which would work together
like a relay team.
The first rover could touch down on the
Martian surface and collect samples by
drilling into rocks
and then stashing the samples
and sealed tubes. Once collected,
the samples would be placed on
the surface to wait for pickup.
A second rover sent later
this follow on rover would
go fetch the samples,
load them into a container
and bring it back to a lander
with a small rocket onboard.
Once the container was loaded on board,
the rocket would lift off carrying
the samples up into Mars' orbit.
Waiting in orbit would be
a third spacecraft and more
butter that could capture
the container and bring it back to her
with Mars samples safely back on
earth scientist around the world.
We'll be able to study them in state of
the art laboratories for decades to come.
The payoff of a sample return is learning
about the potential for life beyond
our home planet and even whether Mars
has the right environment and resources
for human explorers to
survive there one day.
Okay. So that's MSR in a,
in a nutshell with a few,
a few miracles mixed in.
So,
so you guys may think you have coal jobs.
I got the coolest job.
Okay.
They pay me to develop the technologies
to be able to do more sample return.
Like I,
I find myself on a daily basis going,
I just got paid all day to think about
Mars Rovers and they asked me to come
back tomorrow and they're gonna pay
me again tomorrow or I'm so lucky. Um,
we've had sort of three domains and in
a technology development program and so
I'm going to delve much more down
into the details now, um, of,
of technologies to enable Mars sample
return in the 2012 to 2014 timeframe.
We were really trying to get that 2020
rover enabled to be able to collect the
samples. So we were working
hard to develop, you know,
the drill that was going to drill
the sample and not, you know,
turn it into powder,
but keeping it on an integral core.
We want it to do what
we call faster viewers,
which is making it sound as the rover
can cover hundreds of meters per day
instead of the tens of meters that we
typically do with our Mars rovers today.
And we also,
um,
wanted to be able to land more
precisely right now. Um, the,
uh, the MSL mission,
the curiosity mission,
the what we call the landing error lifts
for that was about 10 kilometers by
eight kilometers. And we want to get
down to much closer ones because we can,
as I was saying before, we want to land
close to where the good science is.
So we had to,
within the case of MSL,
we got to row for a couple of
years before we really got to um,
to the good science. We were fortunate
to encounter that stream bed on the way,
but the,
the actual intention for that mission,
we didn't achieve that until
we had road for two years.
So we're trying to be able to reduce
the size of that landing error lips and
land much more precisely. Um, those,
the reason that this is green here is
that those technologies were developed to
the level that they were able to be
infused into the flight mission and there
was all being integrated
into the Mars 2020 mission.
And so we'll have all those capabilities
that we didn't have four for MSL.
The stuff that's in yellow
is in development. Now
I'm going to talk to much,
much more extensively about that in there
and the remaining minutes that we have
have left to develop the math to develop
containment assurance. And then, um,
eventually we're going to have to develop
whatever that system is a comes and
lands the samples back back on earth
and doesn't let the, the egg break open.
And then way down stream we'll start
developing technologies that are not
related to, to MSR. And I'm really
going to talk about MSR today.
So there's a variety of
technologies necessary.
I've touched on a few of them already.
Um,
so I won't spend too
much time on this slide,
but just realize many of them sort
of serve more than one mission in
particularly in the sense that there's
two rovers involved in the sample return
architecture.
Here's what 2020 is all about.
It's highly based on
the curiosity platforms.
So it actually looks very similar to to
curiosity and in fact it was made from
some of the spares from
the curiosity mission.
That's one of the ways we
kept a mission costs down. Um,
but it has a completely different science
package on it that's more oriented
toward trying to find evidence of,
um, of life on Mars and collect those,
those samples.
Um,
it looks identical and certainly the
architecture of the flight system is the
same. We had this crew stage, that
shepherds vehicle from Earth to Mars.
We have a back show,
which is kind of a cover that covers the,
the good stuff inside the payload
during the entry into Mars.
Then we have this descent stage that
you all have seen that that lowers the
rover down to the surface
and then flies away.
The rover itself kind of collapsed down
into Intuit's flat condition before the
wheels are deployed.
And in the bottom is the heat shield.
That's all the same between MSL and 2020
and it's really just the payload is on
the rover. That's, that's
dramatically different.
That's what it looks like when it's all
put together in the clean room at JPL.
Um,
and then as I mentioned before,
we had these key technologies
that we infuse it, the mission.
So we have this model for
technology development.
I mean it's really common across an asset
technology development then infusion
into, into a target
mission application. Um,
as I said before,
we were trying to narrow that,
that landing error lips in the
way that we do it for, for 2020.
That's different from MSL cause we had
this things called terrain relative
navigation.
Um,
it just didn't come up really in any
of the sort of public discussions about
curiosity. But curiosity really didn't
know very much about where it was landing.
We targeted a particular location and we
did our best and navigated through our
best to put the spacecraft there and it
landed very close and I ended within a
kilometer of where we were targeting,
which is fantastic,
but we didn't have any ability to fly
the vehicle to in a particular direction.
And once we actually had it
underneath the parachute,
it's like you pop the shoot and you're
going to land wherever you land.
This is a is intending to allow you to
at least adjust the direction that we go.
So we come down,
we take 10 quick pictures on the way
down and then we decide what direction
we're going to ask the vehicle to go
and we have a divert capability that's
measured in the hundreds
of meters for this.
So this is exaggerating
the situation won't,
it won't keep us from living in the
mountains, but in Atlanta it's in a, in a,
in a more,
in a direction that's more safe.
And then I've been alluding to this
notion that we have a variety of these
sample tubes are going to lay down. We
were going to fly about 40 of them. Um,
we're going to lay them in
in a few different locations.
Probably if things go out the
way we're thinking about it now.
And we'll have what we call depots of
tubes where we have maybe 10 tubes in a,
in a, not a stack but in a
line that the rover would then,
the Fetch rover would then go and collect.
I think you guys have had a
chance to see the sample tubes.
This is kind of what it looks at.
The sample looks like inside the tube.
And then we have two plugs and seals
that are intended to keep the sample from
rattling around during the reentry.
And then also a hermetically seal to make
sure that any of the gases are things
that might be in trained in that sample.
Don't, don't get out so that the,
the engineering of the
sample tubes themselves,
you have a very simple
version of it there.
But the actual samples who was quite
a complex engineering endeavor,
here are some ideas for, um, the,
the architecture of that Sim we call
Samp Srl sample return lander. Um,
it could be something that looks like
the curiosity platform and it carries the
rocket on its back. The rocket is a
little bit larger than human sizes.
It's about three meters in length and
it weighs different ones that have
different masses,
but it's in the 200 to 300 kilo range.
So it's a little heavier than a human
and a little taller than the human,
but it's roughly that size.
You can have it on your back,
which is great because you're picking
up tubes that you don't have to go back
anywhere and you just, when you, when
you decide you have enough tubes,
you finished loading them into
the map and you launch it or are,
we could have one that has a fixed
platform where the mass stays on that
platform in a smaller rover that's
more the size of spirit or opportunity.
Then would go out, collect
the tubes, and then come back.
And does that come back part of it that,
that has us worried and led us to think
about this thing we call a mobile map,
which is, which is the
curiosity class. Um,
there was a variety of different,
um,
autonomy and visualization technologies
that are, that are being applied.
This one is a, is a three
d augmented reality, um,
strategy that we're using not just for,
um,
to put ourselves the operators is the
mission and the scientists from the
mission on the surface of Mars so that
they can look around and say, hey,
I really care about this rock, but
I, I love to see it from the other,
from the other direction.
And using orbital imagery,
we synthesize full three d imagery of the,
of the system so that the operators and
the mission planners can really have a
good situational awareness
of what's happening on Mars.
But we've even thought about doing that
for like spacecraft assembly where you
know,
when you put the space craft together,
it's really tightly packaged and you know,
you wish that you could just
look inside and see what,
what was going on inside there.
And this is a,
this is a way to synthesize the
spacecraft in three d that allow you to
literally walk through the spacecraft
and see what's going on. Dude,
you're the one in interior.
This is that two minute elevator pitch.
The other one is that right now the Mars
Rovers, they actually roll quite slowly.
We've,
we've gotten a hundred meters in a day,
but that's a very good day of driving
and more frequently we're getting tens of
meters per day to do this fetch operation.
We're going to eat a lot better
performance out of out of the rover.
That's going to have some of the driving
distance is a matter of power and
thermal capability of, of the rover
to survive the cold night at Mars.
But a lot of it is that we're just not
smart enough to process the information
quickly enough to allow the rover to
drive and even a walking pace and it would
be wonderful. Right now we're
getting nine meters per day out of,
out of both Mer and MSL. So it's not
a matter of size. Even the rovers,
even though one's much
larger than the other,
they're both rolling along at
10 meters per day. On average.
We need about four or five
times that level of performance.
Then we could get it through.
Um, better automation,
better autonomy,
better decision making onboard the rover
so it can rove and not have to stop.
You know,
when there's a pebble in it's way.
And that's a fantastic application for,
for new technology development in the AI
domain that I think would be great for
this. For this system. I've talked
a little bit about this basketball,
we call it the,
the orbiting sample and what you see are
those sample tubes that I passed around.
We cluster them and it turns out that
when you kind of package them like a
honeycomb and you can
package either 19 of them in,
I think it's four rings,
we're at a fifth ring and you'd get up
to 31 and that's what we're showing here.
33 one,
two.
And then that canister gets slid inside
and it makes up a sphere and there,
and you'll see in a minute why we want
it to be spherical cause it makes it
easier to, to catch it on orbit.
Um, but just, just, sorry,
I just know that way it's
about the size of a basket.
Basketballs 24 centimeters in diameter.
This is 27 and it weighs about 25 pounds.
So it's pretty massive
actually. It's, it's,
and it's almost all metal of some
sort of titanium and stainless steel.
This is just one concept for a massive
launch where we have the platform and
fetched one of the benefits of doing this
versus the Moma Mab is the fetch rover
can kind of back away
and watch the launch.
So we get some fantastic video and also
you wouldn't kill Your rover, right?
If those are the things launches
off the back of the rover,
the rover is not likely
to survive that event.
So this is one advantage to the fetch
and fixed platform. And speaking of mass,
we've been looking at a variety of
different rocket technologies to make this
possible.
There is solid rockets which are liked
the little Estes rockets that as as a kid
I hope you with. Um, there are
the, the what called by propeller.
Rockin switches are analogous to the
space shuttle or what space x as launching
now where you're mixing together
a few on an oxidizer. Um,
the hybrid is kind of halfway in between.
It has a solid fuel,
but either a liquid or a gaseous oxidizer.
And it turns out for the Mars application,
this hybrid is just right because we have
problems with the solids cracking when
they,
when they descend in seventh and they
have to encounter the landing environment
that we have. It's also, um,
they're not very good at, at,
at cycling thermally hot to
cold during the day. And the,
the hybrid fuels don't have that problem.
So we're looking at at a hybrid
implementation for the math.
Okay.
That was the,
the landed system here is the,
here is the, the orbiter system that
would collect the, uh, the sample.
It has big solar arrays because it
actually uses what we call solar electric
propulsion. Rather than using chemical
rockets to propel itself, we, um,
use solar power to heat up an ionized
gas and then gets ejected out.
The back end is a much more
efficient power source.
And this thing called rocks is the,
is the package that captures the sample.
I want to talk a little more about that.
So the rocks system does this,
basketball is in Maura's orbit
and we, and it's a nerd. Okay.
It has no propulsion system.
So what we do is with the orbiter,
we chase it down and we,
we close in on it and we actually find
finally rendezvous with it in the last
sort of hundred meters we closed down.
And that that basketball gets put into
some sort of a system that captures it
and contains and, and
I'm, I'm leading you to,
to another technology that
I wanted to show you. Um,
we have to then either encapsulate it
because it might have more as material on
the outside.
And remember we have to treat that
Mars materials potentially hazardous.
And then we,
because we're so afraid of it,
we actually do it twice and we
do do to encapsulation exercises.
And then we released that
encapsulated systems somehow,
either in the form of a reentry capsule
that lands on the surface or there's
other ideas.
And we've been looking at our
whole variety of different
alternatives to how we
do this rendezvous and capture
it. Summer, very sort of,
let's call them conventional mechanical
things where you fly this thing kind of
into a basket ball and met,
um, that's this one here. Um,
and then you close a loop in any
and you drive it through the system.
There's there, there's another one that
I want to show you that in a second.
That's,
that's really cool.
There's the OSC coming into
the, to the system. Uh,
this one actually uses a mechanical
arms to come and trap the OSCE.
Then, uh, just, you know, this is
all still attached to the spacecraft.
We just delete it so you
can see what's going on.
We reoriented because we care what
orientation those samples land on.
We don't want them to land with the seal
down and be driven through the seal.
So we wanted them to kind
of lay flat when they,
when they land on the earth's surface.
Here we're braising brazing
is like soldering. It's kind
of welding the, uh, the,
the two halves of the
container that the is,
and then it moves into this thing
that we call the earth entry vehicle.
Um, and we do one other
layer of containment there.
So we have a second layer and you'll
see this sort of hangar door thing flip
open and then the Evie gets ejected.
Yeah
and that's, that's the whole
sequence of everything that happens.
Punch it off and there you go.
So I want it to talk about a really
neat technology called flux pinning.
The one scenario that I
just showed you before we,
we capture that oss with mechanical arms.
This one uses,
I'm super conductors and magnets and
it turns out that there was a style of
superconductor type two superconductor
that if you take it through its
transition temperature, you
know, at at higher temperatures,
these things just are sort of
a nerd pieces of metal stuff.
And then if you cool them down and in
this particular class it's below 80
degrees Kelvin,
they become super conductors.
And it turns out that if you do these,
these types of superconductors,
if you take them through the transition
temperature in the presence of a
permanent magnet,
they set up flux fields and these flux
fields are what allow you to levitate
this. This is just a regular
permanent magnet, nothing
special about this one. Um,
it wants to stay in place there. As long
as you hold that superconductor below.
It's critical temperature in the presence
of the magnetic field and wants to pin
that magnet in place.
And that turns out to be extremely
valuable for what we're trying to do.
Um,
on the more sample return.
Yeah.
So we have, um, an idea that we could
try to characterize this, this, uh,
well in order to be able to use it to
capture the OSCE and holding it oriented
in proper position.
So in this context,
the oss would have these permanent
magnets on is on the perimeter, on the,
on the outside of the thing,
and it would fly into the spacecraft.
And then using superconducting
magnets arrayed in this pattern,
we could actually control the
orientation of the awesome.
Not only would capture it
using the superconductors,
we actually could turn it into a,
a preferential orientation
and then trap it down.
And I want it to show you just a
couple of videos from a flight. Here's,
here's an operation at Cornell on a,
on a flat table,
but I'll also show you a operational,
we just did in,
in March on a micro gravity a aircraft.
We flew this thing because on the flat
table we only get three degrees of
freedom, right? It goes x
and Y and you can get y'all,
but you're not getting all six degrees.
Is He pitch you on role?
So actually this on the uh,
on the micro gravity airplane aware.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay. Day One before
the guy learns. Don't,
don't try to stand
on one of these. Gravel is a
good about 20 seconds. Okay.
Anytime we get about three
or four seconds. Good. Zero
days. Let me just show you.
Yeah,
this is from camera. It's bounded
on the frame. That's mine.
I see how it just for a couple seconds
got in there. Everybody was really jagged.
Yeah,
there's a particularly good,
yeah.
So it turns out there
if anything happens, if you
touch any, anything in a plane,
you're no longer together.
Oscar is pouring out.
So you'll see how far we actually
translate in the plane in zero g.
So we do get to have some fun
every once in a while. Um,
and we're thinking about flying this on
the space station in a couple of years
and then eventually in,
in Morris,
this is simulating the landing of that
Earth entry vehicle on the desert floor
at 3000 g's.
And that's on a muddy.
It could rain and in the desert and we
were testing and what happens when it
lands in mud and what it does and it
just creates this huge splatter of blood.
So I'm showing you the fun stuff,
right? I'm not showing you,
it was me sitting in meetings
all day long and you know,
developing budgets and schedules,
I'm showing anymore.
We get to fly on the micro gravity playing
and when we get to make the mud goes
splat.
Okay,
so downstream after this we have big
ideas about other systems that could
explore Mars, helicopters, balloons,
landing more things,
and eventually getting ready for humans.
So sorry for the fast close there,
but there's,
if you're really interested in,
please ask Mary for the slide package
and you can look at it and warranty FTL
and I'm happy to talk with you off
offline. All right, thank you very much.
I know I hit you with a fire hose.
Perfect.
I'm wondering with the sort of idea of uh,
the magnetic capture, sort
of firstly, what are the,
does that have a long enough range
to be practically useful in orbit?
It feels like it would be range
constraint more than a basket and sort of
secondly,
what were the reasons to
use superconducting methods
instead of active control
with a regular little
electromagnet to accomplish
that task? Sure. So first fifth,
two fantastic questions.
Number one,
it would be beautiful if this tractor
beam acted over kilometers and you know,
it was just like in Star Trek, but
it acts over centimeters. The good,
the good news is we can control the
spacecraft to single digit centimeter.
So I can fly about retrieval system up
to the oss within about five centimeters.
So I only need that
tractor beam quality to,
to actuate over single digit centimeters.
And it does that.
That's that aspect of the really
important thing is that we do it without
contacting,
without getting a lot of dust flying
off of the OSCE and contaminating the
spacecraft.
That's,
that's the big advantage over the
conventional mechanical muses.
And we never actually touched the awesome
the scenario it comes in and it pins
in that equilibrium condition
with no contact to the spacecraft.
And we're able to orient the oss without
touching it. And it turns out that,
that this orientation function
is winding up being a big design.
I didn't think it would be when
we first embarked on this thing,
but it turns out that orientation is
a big design driver for the mechanical
systems on.
The second one is,
why do we do it with superconductors
rather than just regular commissional
magnus? You could, but that,
that potential well and
that pinning capability in,
in the equilibrium position is a lot
more difficult to synthesize with
electromagnets and wants to drive right
into contact with a magnet and stick in
contact.
Now you can levitate electromagnetically
but it's a lot harder than this.
Too much does it passively.
So as long as you keep that superconductor
below it's critical temperature.
As long as you're keeping it that cold,
you don't have to do anything else.
You don't need an elaborate
control system. It just,
it just operates that way as long as
you've pinned the magnet in place. So yes,
you could do it with electromagnets,
but the,
the superconductors have a number of
characteristics that are beneficial.
That passive equilibrium position,
the non contact case instead of
those things make it advantageous.
The downside is it's a low
technology maturity right now.
And so we're inventing
the technology as we go.
Most people have much more experience
obviously with electromagnets,
a conventional permanent magnets.
So those things are intention
in our development. Thank you.
That's a super question.
I actually had a similar question but I'll
go with a different one cause you, uh,
you answered my first one.
I'd to know a little bit about,
um, the relationship between NASA and
space x and how much coordination there is
between the two organizations and
how much competition there might be.
Yeah. Uh, another, another
great question and I'll,
and I'll going to do my best to be a
candid but with a little bit of diplomacy.
So, um, number one is, as I mentioned
to you on, you know, really,
really impressed with all the things
that space x has been able to accomplish.
Um, we, uh, especially at JPL,
but Nasa Ames also has a
relationship with space x. Um,
we're helping them do some of the
things that they really can't do for
themselves.
Like for instance,
we're talking with them about some of the
really technical aspects of the entry,
descent and landing environment so that
they understand some of the lessons that
we learned the hard way without having
to repeat them. And so we're off.
We're providing them with some engineering
support as they develop their system.
And then there's other areas where
they're not looking for that support.
They think they have the answer and they,
and they may even have the personnel
that have the experience that are able to
give them that.
So we're supporting them as some very
particular engineering domains in areas
where NASA has clear expertise that
space x does not have in return.
Um,
there are discussions between space x
and NASA about returning the favor in the
form of landing things for us because
we're only getting opportunities to land
on the Mars surface every half a
decade or so if they're going on every
opportunity to be wonderful if we
could put payloads onto their system.
So there's, there's a bit
of an interchange and there,
there are motivations on,
on both sides for, for
that relationship. Um,
one thing I can say is that I think
SpaceX is really changing the paradigm.
They certainly had done it in the launch
vehicle game and I anticipate that as
they spread into other domains
like spacecraft satellites, um,
like from Mars applications,
they're going to change the paradigm
in the way that they did for launch
vehicles. They're going to change
the paradigm in those other domains.
I happen to be somebody who thinks that
those paradigm changes are good for the
ecosystem as a whole.
So I'm really a huge fan of space x and
I think most people that you talk to at
JPL aims have sort of
a similar perspective.
So I'm somewhat curious if there's been
any lessons learned from rubber attempts
of like other countries and uh,
because you know,
most of what we see is coming
from NASA or maybe space x,
but we don't see much coming
at least, uh, publicized from,
from the other countries,
right. In the domain of
Mars exploration. Um,
particularly when we talk about
landing things on Mars and,
and using them on Morris,
the u s is kind of the only
player that's been successful. Um,
we actually have a very,
one of the slides that I didn't show
you guys today is we have a scorecard of
successful attempts versus successes and
it's like 39 at Townson 15 successes.
And almost all of those successes are us.
No one,
no other country has successfully landed
something on Mars that lasted for more
than a few seconds.
The Russians landed something that
died in a matter of seconds. Um, we,
the only the only country
that's ever had anything that,
that really delivered science back from
the surface of Mars is the United States.
Now, that's not to say that we don't
have wonderful collaborations with other
international partners like the European
Space Agency that are providing things
on the instrument level,
and they're now getting to the point
of trying to do things like rovers.
The Europeans are planning to launch a
rover mission in 2020 that would sort of
look like spirit and opportunity
in terms of its ambitions for,
for size and roving,
distance and so forth.
But no one's really yet been successful
at the, let's call it the mission level.
Um, uh, other than NASA.
So right now the collaborations
are at the instrument level,
but I'm the mission level. We're still
waiting for them to catch up. Um,
I'm wondering why you have
the second rover at all.
I mean if you just kept all the things
on the first rover and you say the rocket
that's coming is going to be able
to land, you know, on a dime.
We're not just land next to it.
Yeah,
I guess I'm never going to get
an easy questions for you guys.
Very insightful question and yes you
could do this with one single landed
element,
but let me explain technical motivations
and also allude to some programmatic or
motivations.
Technically the mission that it's going
to take to collect those samples are
going to take a couple of
years on the Mars surface.
And while we've had,
you know,
we've had great success spirit lasted
seven years. Opportunity is, is 12 years,
curiosity is now when it's what,
fifth year, six year of operation.
We can't count on those
super long mission durations,
particularly the solar power systems.
If they ever get themselves
in a conditioning where
they're sort of stuck and
they can't point, there were rays at the
sun over the winter, the Mars winter,
they freeze to death.
So we're very reluctant to bake into our
mission planning multi year missions.
And we think that that collection process
is going to take a couple of years,
and so it kind of eats up the amount of
time that we're willing to allocate to a
single mission. Um, the
collection operation,
it actually takes less
time then the sample.
When I say collection,
I mean the fetching operation
at collecting the sample
tubes from the surface
takes much less time than the,
than the drilling of the cores and
laying those samples down on the surface.
And we're just nervous that that's too
much to pack into one single mission.
That's the technical explanation.
There's a programmatic explanation that
says we're sending the Mars 2020 mission
to Mars to do a fantastic
institchu mission, which by
the way stands on its own.
We would send that system,
I believe,
regardless of whether or not there
was a sampling package on it.
But it's great that we have the sampling
package and we get started on Mars
sample return. Um, and we built
some momentum that says, Hey, um,
uh, Congress and the
Congressional Budget Office,
we have 33 sample tubes
lying on the surface of Mars.
They have unbelievable science
locked inside them, please,
let's go get them and bring them home.
That's a compelling story that gets to
be told starting in 2021 when the 2020
rover lands rather than betting on the
come and sending that mission in 2027
2028 and hoping that
you have good samples.
So the opportunity to get started soon
have something that's compelling to bring
back helps to motivate
the rest of the missions.
So I told you a technical story and I
told your programmatic store in both of
those combined are why we have separate
missions for caching and in return we
could conceivably do it on one mission,
but it makes more sense to do it in two.
Yeah.
So the,
the question for those of you who
couldn't hear the question was do these,
these two rovers that are
participating in sample return,
do they have a mission after they've
completed their through sampling, um,
responsibilities and the answer certainly
in the case of 2020 and the answer is
an emphatic yes. Um, it
as I, as I said before,
it has an instrument package that's
doing in such science in addition to the,
to the sampling operation that Institchu
science can happen before your collect
samples, while you're collecting samples,
after you collect samples and as a,
after I just told this story that we're
afraid of the rovers aren't going to
last very long.
The reality is they do in practice the
last for a long time and we anticipate
after we finished that
sample caching mission,
if the rover is still going strong,
we would continue the science mission.
The one that's a little bit more sort
of not clear at this point is the fetch
rover and as I showed you on that,
that one image that showed the Mab launch
where we had a small fish rover that
could stand off from the Mab launch
and observe it from a safe distance.
That one we expect that the,
hopefully the rover would survive that
Bab launch and go on to do more science.
The mobile math where you're carrying
the map on your back and you and you put
it into his launch
orientation and off it goes,
that one probably trashes the rover and
we been thinking about ways to maybe,
you know, put the, the, the, the
rocket off the back of the rover.
So it's not thrusting directly
down onto it, but, but that, that,
that fetching mission also the,
the,
the amount of science instrumentation
that we would be able to put on that
system, which is already doing
the Malveaux and everything,
it's a much more questionable thing.
So I think 2020 is going to,
it's going to do a good ancillary science
mission air regardless of the sampling
operation.
The ability of the Fetch rover to,
to continue to do more
science is questionable.
So that's playing into the
architecture of the missions.
Okay.
So Brian wants to know,
how are you planning to get the necessary
amount of maneuvering capability to
rendezvous with the OSTP given that
the vehicle uses an eye on drive.
Great.
Five for five,
what? Ask me like why Mars is
red or something like that.
Please send me a softball and I
could smash out of the field. Now,
um,
we'll,
we'll actually augment that ion thrusting
system with a cold gas thrusters
system specifically for the purpose
of doing the, the rendezvous function.
And we could not execute the rendezvous
purely with the low thrust engines that
you have when you're doing ion thrusting.
So it'll be cold gas,
either hydrazine or maybe even xenon.
That was the pressure and it was,
was the gas that we're blowing
out of the ion thruster,
we might be able to use some
spare a xenon for that function.
It turns out in practice,
hydrazine has a much more packs,
so much more powerful punch.
And so it's better for us to
use hydrazine as the fluid,
but we will not try to do
it with the ion engines.
We do the rendezvous with a cold
gas or, or, or hydrazine system.
Is there any consideration to
have more than one sample return?
The returning vertical,
for example,
collecting more samples opportunistically.
And two,
we were able to collect more than send
another mission liking next five years.
Right.
So the question was,
is there a perhaps a motivation to have
multiple sample returns either from the
sample set?
Um,
I'm gonna extend a little bit on your
question either from the samples that we
take from 2020,
um,
or multiple sample return
missions themselves on the
answer. The answer is yes.
Uh,
we were going to carry,
right now the plane is security a little
more than 40 of these sample tubes and
we'll collect as many as we can. We'll lay
as many on the surface as, as possible.
My guess is that none of them
are going to be such duds that,
that we would want not want
to bring them back. Right. Um,
there's going to be a fantastic
scientific debate on whether we bring back
sample two, four, six, nine,
etc. Which ones we bring back.
But we're,
we're most likely not going to be able
to bring back every single tube that we,
that we collect.
So there,
there would be a strong motivation to
want to return all of those tubes. Um,
furthermore,
we're only going to be able to land at
one site and do science and that one
location.
And while we're trying to pick landing
sites that have a diversity of potential,
um, scientific return, it
is only one place. And then
just like on earth, you know,
you can,
it's not the same thing to vacation in
Hawaii as it is to vacation in Finland.
And so we would,
we would want to go to other places on
Mars and return samples from multiple
locations that of course a required
different mission to do the sample
collection of caching.
Also, as you can tell from,
from what I've described to you so far,
we're making are rather large
investment in the technology for this.
And it would be great to see it amortized
over multiple missions rather than
just one singular one. So we can, we,
we can envision multiple sample
return missions either to finish,
kind of finished the job if there's
still good samples left from the first
mission or to have multiple sample returns
flown from different landing sites,
different samples,
suites.
So,
so now that we have pretty strong evidence
that there was a historical flowing
liquid water on Mars,
um,
would that have potentially impacted,
uh,
kind of the coloration or the planet
such that they're red planet was not
historically?
Right.
That's a,
that's a hard question as a easy question.
So I'm not kidding. You've stumped
me more with that question then.
With all the previous ones
that have come, uh, you know,
the red plants red because it's iron
oxide in the soil. That's why it's red.
The presence of liquid water didn't really
affect the fact that desire and oxide
exists on Mars. I think that,
that, that's not necessarily,
the water's not necessary
for that iron oxide to form,
so that the connection between
color and presence of water, um,
I may have a scientific colleague
who's going to make my phone buzz in a,
in a as 80. Oh, no,
you're wrong. Um, but I,
I think that those are relatively
disconnected phenomena.
Thank you again.